From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
You got a ride, is it true of life?
Can't all the little children be more guided by you?
Can't you got a ride, is it true of life?
Can't you get a ride, we've all got a ride, can't you get a ride, is it true of life?
Is there a guide, Caroline?
And this is a candidate, Anderson, Caroline, and Heidi Hoskins today at the Highlanders Center in Newark, Tennessee.
My name is Joe Manier of the Southern or History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with Nikki John Bishop, our videographer, and we are here to be an interview for the Civil Rights History Project.
It is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Today is Monday September 19, 2011, and the coding note, the Billets, no it's key.
Thank you for the warm welcome, it's just a wonderful pleasure to be with you.
Thank you.
I thought we might start talking a little bit about 1960 and the two of you meeting at Highlanders.
How then brought you both in the middle of the room?
Well, Highlanders hosted the first gathering of people who have been involved in the city in April 1st, 1960, that's from Highlanders in Lani, Tennessee.
And I was already working at Highlanders as a volunteer, having come in 1959.
And I came up with the delegation of students from Nashville, having been involved in the city and there.
It was just an incredible weekend.
I mean I could start with a part of the guy and I meeting each other.
He was teaching songs and we had some songs in Nashville, we've been in jail and we have some singing that sort of keep our spirits up.
But we didn't have what I would call freedom songs.
And he taught us, I'm going to stay at the left and table, keep your eyes on the prize and we shall overcome.
And I know, but the people from Nashville, that was just so incredible to have those songs because they were so perfect.
And I think for the students from around the South, that was true.
But he was an incredible weekend in other ways.
Miles Horton, the director of Highlanders, and two or three other people used the Highlander process, which is asking a lot of really questions that really got you thinking.
And that you're thinking beyond what you've done so far to think about next steps.
And we had breakout sessions on what the meaning of non-violence is, whether it was a tactic or a philosophy for what was our relationship with the adult communities that had already been working to try to discommunicate segregation.
What about the notion that we're arrested rather than coming out and taking all that bail money?
Staying in jail to put more pressure on the system.
So there's just a range of questions that we struggled with at weekend and it was a very heavy, just to meet the other people who have been involved in similar situations.
I don't know about Guy's memory. He was such an important part of that weekend, but I don't know if you remember the moment you met me.
Oh boy! How do I do you?
Or a few other things.
I know other people that we've talked to remember that whenever the meeting got too heavy or the questions were too hard or whatever Guy would go off in the room with his guitar and James Bevel and Bernard Lafayette and others would go in there with him and they would just keep the singing going.
I mean that's actually been true at Islander historically.
It's always that it was really hard problems and press people to make the decisions that they've always used the effort to culture to enable people to take on some of those high things and to keep their spirits and technologies a lot of music and dance and food and humor.
So it's part of the timing of the process, I'm sure. To ask something that I'm sure many of the asked, could you maybe say a word for calling the things that spring most quickly came on and you think about those things that's of the Clark or the most important.
That's a little bit about September Guy because you were her driver, you know, those early days at high.
Great lady.
Did you feel like it was, did you feel like you'd fallen into a pretty good job when Miles asked you to drive, stepped in the round.
No, that was incredible to be able to meet her driver. I just calm down and listen to my superior.
I went to speed up and went to slow down. I love her.
I think she took her wing in many ways and told him when he needed to dress up a little bit, you know, about going to the church of the Island and just kind of helped his behavior.
They got into trouble several times too because of course Guy would have stepped in the front seat.
And so they were slapped a lot of times by the police wondering why this black woman sitting in the front seat.
He was the younger white man.
Anyway, those are small things. I mean, stepped in was a huge influence on both of us, just sexualized person.
A surprising person because, you know, we think of her as a great symbol of non-violence within the Dr. King.
But I remember when we were raising our little son on John's Island and she was our neighbor in Charleston.
She would say, well, don't take all his little toy guns away from him.
And letting play with his toy guns and get it out of the system now, you deny them the use of those guns, the loom large in his life.
And he might want them when he's a teenager.
You know, she was just a very sensible person about things like that.
And very tough. I mean, people think of her as a sweet woman.
But she was a tough woman that she had to be, to be at Mad Eagle up on the top of a mountain that was just a total white community and working with miles and those guns and some of the men there.
I mean, she had to be very strong and very great, and she was that.
So, you know, she's just a very important influence on us.
And we can talk forever about miles. You want to say anything about miles?
A very strong person.
We think of miles as just an educational visionary.
He really was so smart about the kind of education that was practiced at home.
It is practiced at home here that's very much building on people's own experiences and getting people to think about what they really already know.
But he was so down the earth in his sense of humor and his method of talking.
He never made anybody feel at least that intimidated.
He always made people feel very comfortable.
But he also wouldn't let you get away with anything if you said something really done.
He would, you know, get you to think about it in a different way.
So, he was, yeah, I just, somebody really important, I think, strategically,
educationally for the civilized movement and for the labor movement.
And certainly, I mean, they wouldn't be highly under it.
Miles hadn't been one of the founding directors in stay with it.
We always try to remind people that Highlander has always been a team of people working
and they've always been women as well as growing their director.
But his educational vision really was so he and the skill they live in here that you're living.
He's still a living person.
The question about what was it when you think back that motivated a young woman,
college age in California, to come all the way to Fiskini, Westby, in exchange to,
that was obviously something that a small and for people good, but not many.
And why did you want to be that?
Well, I'm first saying, and say, as I grew up in a family with very progressive ideas
and a very strong idea about fairness and equality for everyone.
You know, so I mean, I heard it all my life in the unitarian fellowship I went to
in the Girl Scouts, all these things about treating people fairly.
And then when I was in high school, the Montgomery bus port at the place
and what it was the thing began to get national publicity.
And all of that was just very interesting to me.
I remember studying some about Dandy also when I was in high school.
One thing I'd say is growing up in the 1950s, you're part of the silent generation.
You know, and there's a lot of fear because of the authority here.
And that was another thing when we first got our television set.
One of the first things we watched with the authority here is my father,
which is absolutely limited about them.
And, you know, so when something began to stir in the sound, it was like,
oh, maybe something else is possible.
Somebody's not going to be so sorry with it.
And I heard about the fiscal change program when I was going to high school.
Somebody came back to my high school from Pomona College and talked about having gone
on this interesting program and that sounds quite interesting.
And that made me especially interested in Pomona.
I was looking at some other colleges as well.
My father liked Pomona very much just for other reasons.
He's got a very good academic name.
So we agreed I should have applied there and I applied in Linda Pomona.
And my sophomore year, one of my very good friends went to this.
And the person she exchanged with, Mary had a doctor, became my roommate at Pomona.
So when I was in junior and a lot of my friends were making their friends to go abroad
and they'd do a new year, whatever, that's when I applied to go on the fiscal change program.
And my family was just so lucky because I happened to go in January of 1960.
And that semester between January and June 1960 was just such a crucial time in Nashville.
I was just lucky enough to be there.
Among the materials and wonderful collection at the Southern Disturbed Collection at Chapel Hill,
I enjoyed sitting down with some of the teachers where you came up to this visit.
And I listened to an interview that you gave, recording of an interview that you gave on the campus.
I think it probably guessing, it wasn't dated, but probably guessing that fall after you returned
still in the 1960s, you were going back to the fire spring.
And one thing that you mentioned, you were describing broadly the whole city movement in Nashville
and with jailing and trial.
And so, but you also said one thing on it asked about that you recalled that an end of the ACP meeting.
Still with an end January, someone came and said, hey, you know what, there's going to be a sit-in in Greensboro coming up pretty soon.
Does it give any recollection of that?
In other words, that throughout the end of the ACP network, there was already a sense that Greensboro was picking up.
And I remember that.
What I mostly remember is, you know, we were already having non-violent trainings at Pist that Reverend James Lawson was running.
And we felt like we were preparing for something, but we didn't know what.
And I can just remember the electric feeling when that Greensboro city indeed came place.
And the news came to an end, so we said, oh, well that's what we're, that's what we need to do.
So I don't remember so much the mention of it before that.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, you're welcome to talk about the use of being quite important.
Oh, no, we won't say anything.
Okay, we'll go back after a short break, yeah.
We'll certainly be seeing that, unfortunately, the cells and stuff.
For the early particular songs, it would mean both particular and both of you.
Well, we had one song that was a four runner to a freedom song.
It was to this spiritual A-man, A-man, using civil rights, civil rights justice.
So that was important.
We did it over and over again.
But what I remember is just everybody having to tap into whatever they knew.
You know, there were a lot of kind of rock and roll songs.
There were what I would call camp songs.
There were a lot of religious songs that people had learned in church.
But there wasn't so much the notion that really we would get once we met guy about taking those religious songs and adapting them.
Just changing a few words and, you know, it would become freedom song.
Yeah, so I don't...
Who you call yourself on film more than one of the more of the things that you've learned.
Yeah, which is a song and I sang that I had learned.
Probably from guy.
I'm not sure about it because we also important in Nashville with the mass meetings,
which would happen two or three times a week as the whole community came together and, you know, really supported the sit-in of the man.
There was always a lot of singing in those meetings.
I also...
I don't know if I talked about it in that speech, but I know what I felt at the time.
I'd always loved music and I'd always been active in choirs and little quartets and things at high school.
But I had never seen music like I saw in Nashville in those mass meetings where it was community music.
You know, powerful, powerful community music for everybody saying together, I didn't have that experience.
I don't know if you know, but you know, but you know, you're in fellowships.
We didn't think like that.
You didn't tell us.
You know, anyway, that was important.
You would marry and the two of you would work so centrally in building out a music culture in the movement.
And I wonder if you might share reflections about some of the places that effort took you because you were in the thick of so much.
Well, I'm just so sorry guys, I'm not going to pull all these memories out.
And I just want to say a little bit more about him because in those years, I mean, he was very much my teacher.
You know, my experience in music was really limited when I could get involved in the movement.
Guy on the other hand had had a whole experience in Los Angeles working with the people songs.
He'd met a family, the Oliver family in Los Angeles.
They had introduced him to a range of people using music politically.
The whole history of the labor movement and the way music continues, and through them, he met people like Pete Seeger.
He'd also, I don't know, exact coming on this, but he'd studied a little folklore at Occidental College.
But then he went on to UCLA where he got his master's degree in sociology.
And that's where he got to listen to all the library of congress recordings and learn about the work of the low maxes.
And here, Southern music, black and white, you know, Southern music, and one funny story.
Guy, you're going to have to correct me if I'm wrong on this now.
But Whale in Hand was one of his teachers at UCLA and wasn't he the president of the American folklore society.
He warned guy, because guy was writing some papers about more of the political uses of music.
And he warned guys, and well, you know, you can hang out with people like Pete Seeger if you want to.
But what you really need to do is just let a folks on be a folks on.
This could really be corrupt and so look at the way the Germans and the Nazis took their folk music and used it, you know, in a right wing movement.
And said, you're much better to just let a folks on be a folks on.
And I always laughed about that because obviously Guy didn't take that to his area.
But all is to say, you know, well, I'm going to back that for one more thing to once Guy did meet Pete Seeger at a party.
And to thank the Ken and heard him play the banjo.
You know, he said, came home that night and dreamed about banjo.
Pete is the one that told Guy about Highlander. Guy told Pete he wanted to travel around the South and see where his parents had grown up.
Charleston South Carolina for his mother.
We're all North Carolina for his father and he said, oh, it's a great idea for you to travel a South.
And he said, you should visit a place called Highlander folks school because that's a place where there's a lot of music.
And they're using it, you know, as part of people struggles.
So, you know, summer of 1953, Guy goes around the South with Ramley, Jack Elliott and Frank Hamilton.
And they end up spending a couple of weeks at Highlander.
I mean, obviously that was a really important visit. I'm just going to impact the rest of Guy's life.
So, just, I mean, to get back to your question, I mean, I was lucky enough to meet Guy and we were married in 1961.
And, you know, I just became his helper in those early years.
He was the one that was invited out to Southern communities.
As people came to Highlander to workshops about the civil rights movement,
Guy would be there to teach songs that he knew but also learn songs that people brought with him.
And people in black communities like that, I think they thought it was a novelty.
Here's this Dorothy Katten, who'd say, tall skinny white boy with a guitar, who liked this music.
And so he was invited to many, many, many communities around the South to come and go into the churches.
They didn't like him playing the band during the churches, but the guitar was fine.
You know, once we were married, I was just walking in a big ol' with him a part of the time.
I mean, there are lots of stories we could tell about that in the Clarksdale, Mississippi.
He was invited to do a joint concert with a young woman who was studying opera, Mary Jane Piguet.
Mrs. Piguet is the one that invited Guy and so they did a joint concert.
Guy didn't spoke songs and Mary Jane did her opera that she was learning.
She was a wonderful concert.
But when we left the church, Mrs. Clarksdale, Mississippi, we were followed by the police.
Well, first of all, community members said, well, we're going to follow you out of town now because it's very dangerous.
You're in the black part of town, they know you're here.
So we were escorted by the police practicing, and I was very pregnant at the time.
I mean, they took us right off to jail.
So, you know, we had our ups and downs.
Mostly, we had the warmth of civil rights communities welcoming us into their churches and into their homes.
I mean, I could just speak for myself. I was just learning a whole thing about American society that I was so privileged to be learning.
And I know Guy always knew a lot more musically than I did.
But I think he was also learning about the strength of communities when they start organizing the notions that you could build a different kind of pantry.
Very rich times.
Hey, man. Hey, woman.
Could we do a bit of a song or two that were a song that...
Why don't you get that other guitar?
Because it's tuned up, you could do...
I think the price of the guitar is in the right kind of song.
Paul and Silas found in jail and the one for the golden bells.
Keep your eyes on the prize.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
Shall overcome.
We shall overcome.
Someday, oh deep in my heart, I do believe.
Someday.
Here's the smile, Switzerland.
Make us free.
The truth will make us free.
Someday, oh deep in my heart, I do believe.
We shall overcome.
Someday.
I mentioned that before we started the community Jones,
and the community Jones had recalled the evening of a raid at Pylinder,
and in the dark someone called out to...
We are not afraid.
The first came on, and I know it's very much discussion.
Well, I'm pretty sure that's where that verse...
I mean, somebody else might have thought about it in another situation,
of course, but Jamila, Maryeth Indose,
she was like 13 years old, young teenagers there with an adult group from Montgomery,
and she's the one that started humming that,
and just hopped that verse right in there in a very intense situation.
Yeah.
I guess I'd like to say something about...
I know guys are going to go down in history as a person who was able to do this.
I'm sure of a family, you know, to the sitting students and the founding meeting in SNCC,
but you know, that was almost just serendipity.
I mean, we happened to be in the right place at the right time.
To me, much more important, what I did, for the next five years,
was how, what a big hearty had about music,
and about drawing music, kind of, like the people,
and encouraging people like Jamila, Betty Mayfax,
and the people who were the really beautiful representatives of that movement,
and guys' role in just giving them so much encouragement,
and helping them get to places where they'd be very getting the freedom seniors up to the Newport folk foundation.
I mean, he was just very generous about giving support to other people.
And I think the other thing that's really important in our history is the workshops
that Guy was able to organize to bring together the song leaders of the Newport.
And I give Miles a lot of credit for this, too.
Miles was not a singer himself, of course he'd been married to Zopian,
who was a beautiful singer, but he was very appreciative of how powerful the music can be
in support of movement, building.
And so whenever Guy felt it was time to bring people together in a musical setting,
Miles and Hyde are the gatekeepers to support the new music,
and between 1965, we were able to organize five or six really key workshops,
some at Hyde under, but mostly out in the South, in Atlanta, and in Mississippi.
And Guy was so good about getting on the phone and sending out a letter,
not so much the specific individuals, but the communities,
and say, Sanders, your song leaders, you know, we're going to share repertoire,
we're going to learn from each other and help, you know, this incredible movement music that's grown.
So those workshops were very key.
And another thing that I always was impressed about Guy,
in 1961, in the summer, we were living at Hyde under,
and it was the period when so many people had gone to jail in the freedom lives,
and they were all in Mississippi, having gone to parchment in a country,
and they were going to come out, be released in Jackson,
and somebody called Guy and then by again, to come down and lead singing.
So it gets down to the release of the Freedom Writers in Jackson,
to leave singing, and he suddenly realized that these people are living jail together for months,
and maybe not even one to leave singing.
They knew plenty of songs, and the songs were just bursting out of them,
and he just consciously said to himself, well, I'm going to shift my role now.
There's another role that I can play that has to do with documenting this growing repertoire.
And so that's when he bought a big Ampex tape recorder and began getting around the south of the recording.
The songs of the movement, and he knew that people making the movement were too busy to document themselves,
but he also knew having a relationship with Moash,
it's both ways records and publications.
He knew that there would be a way to get documentary materials out nationally.
So he just kind of turned in his work with him,
or at that point he became more documented, and I thought that was very good,
that he recognized that it was time to do that.
Could you speak a little more about Moash and how he related to the recording of his film in general?
Can you talk a little bit about Mo, Guy, and your relationship to him?
Moash?
That's a long time ago.
But you needed people who helped a lot to have people who could play guitars or banjos or no songs,
have a repertoire of songs that would say how you felt or how a group of people have gone through bad experiences
could make, try to make some good out of it,
and freedom songs, and standing together, making use of the songs.
You guys always given Mo a lot of credit.
I mean, here's Moash, who's running Folkways Records,
is putting out music from around the world, and music from people's struggles,
and I guess by the time Guy got really involved in the movement,
so he put out his own three albums on Folkways and his own scene.
So he had a good relationship with Moash, and when he placed himself in the South,
Mo said to him, send me anything you've got.
So Guy knew when he started recording that there was going to be an outlet for things on long play records,
and that was really helpful.
And the relationship with publications, the same way, or until there was the editor at that point,
any songs that got sent to him, you know,
could come out in a little magazine that's going to go around the country.
And the first collection of songs that we could in book form, which all over town,
put that out, but they did it for its nick.
It was a sneak publication, even freedom songs coming out of the movement.
So I've heard Guy deal a lot of credit to both Moash
and their Went Silver Matt relationship in terms of helping with this documentary,
the side of his work.
What about other ways that we've now put to life as an interface that help promote
or get distributed to someone?
Well, I learned it self-din many of that, you know,
remember the new meagrapher machine?
Even starting back when Zelvia was still alive.
You know, she had died in 1956, but she, you know, had this role of encouraging music
in the labor struggle.
And so some little meagrapher song, which came out of that work,
and then Guy's first role, Sing for Freedom in the summer of 1960 at Highlander.
That was all meagrapher.
And now he went the next year to the annual conference of SCLC,
Martin Luther King's organization, and he grappled down there with these meagrapher songs.
Many of the meagrapher songs, Sheets from Highlander,
and I believe also the Nashville City and Story, you know,
you can have a wonderful one.
So of course that time he got stabbed by the police,
and they confiscated all his materials.
Oh, goodness.
I guess broadside is another, you know,
the same time this work is going on in the South,
there's a folk revival going on in the North,
and there are people writing songs about what they see in the country,
including the South, people like Tom Paxton and Bella Oaks,
and Bob Dylan and so broadside was another publication
putting out some of that material.
I think of that as not being distributed so much in the South.
That was more for people in the folk revival in the North.
So I don't think broadside was as widely seen in the South.
You mentioned your experience in the Mass meetings in Nashville
as something that first brought you into that experience of community music.
And I wonder if you might just say a little bit about that.
Oh, wow.
Paul and Silas, man in jail,
and the one for the Golden Bay.
Keep your eyes on the pride,
through now, hold on, hold on.
Hold on, keep your eyes on the gold.
Keep your eyes on the gold.
Keep your eyes on the pride,
through now, hold on.
Hold on, keep your eyes on the pride,
through now.
I was going to have fun before we get that last break to just the lighting.
You could talk a little bit more about the sense of community
that carried the movement through song,
that sense of...
You had to be a...
It's hard to talk about.
First of all, just the sense of community and movement
and the idea that you're building a beloved community.
I mean, it seems so far from the way we are in this country now.
It's all become so cynical.
But in those days, we would pull a hope.
We really thought things would change.
Looking back at the 50th anniversary of SNCC,
we went to a lot of big change.
The music was extremely important.
I liked it when John Lewis said,
well, the movement without its music would be like a bird without its wing.
That was really poetic.
When I heard Guy talk a lot about the music and movement overall,
he's always good to point out that there were songs for every mood.
There were very jubilant songs.
There were the very sad songs when someone was killed.
There were the songs you used to play.
There were all the humor when you could find people with sati.
And then Bernice Rigen, you know,
we worked together on the We Shall Overcome Fund,
which distributes the royalties
for when We Shall Overcome is used commercially.
And those royalties go back into the South, into Southern communities.
And we have an annual meeting.
And I heard Bernice talk about the power of the music as a non-violent tool.
And I heard that when you're up against such powers of oppression
and you're not going to use violence,
but you need things that help you feel strong and that show your strength,
she talked about how aggressive the music was.
And that's one thing that pulled her into the movement in Albany
because of its the aggressiveness and the power of the music.
So, yeah, I don't like it when sort of non-violence gets described
as something more passive or just there'll be songs.
We all across our own,
and some We Shall Overcome, the copy of our ear.
I think all of that just so short,
the actual power that this music had in those times
when people were really in motion in this country.
And then I would say that a lot of those songs have moved into other movements
because they still convey that power.
So, you know, in Geistra here,
we went on to work here at Hiring Dude with waves of other groups of people
working on other issues that those songs translate
because they do, yeah, they carry that spirit of change.
Is there an example of a sad or a satirical song that comes along?
Which I want to share?
We're not sure if it's singing those,
but we love those songs with the Nashville Portette,
that you know, you better leave sacred ancient and live
because they love sacred ancient like a hand,
our gloves above.
Did you interview Bernard Lockie at you?
Okay, because he's really good at thunderous thunder.
Or in my dog, what your dog,
in your dog's mind,
so why can't we sit under the apple tree?
You know, I mean,
and then I mean in terms of,
I don't know if it's sad so much,
but when people began to feel like
we shall overcome this too optimistic,
and also when we got a little cooperative and used
in so many situations,
people switched over and began singing,
we'll never turn back,
which has a different kind of a spirit to it.
And I mean, even these days,
when you go to gatherings,
people don't like nostalgia about this stuff,
I don't either, I don't feel nostalgic about it.
But you know, if we'll sing,
we shall overcome often somebody will say,
well, it's also sing,
we'll never turn back,
you know, it's a little different kind of a spirit
and yeah, but I'm not going to sing it.
Very well.
I'm sure there must have been many times
when you had ample calls to be fearful,
and I wonder how you kind of confronted
that fear as a chronic part of living in a context,
like this outfit, those years.
I just hate to be doing things so much, Shoggi.
And I think about that particular question,
I mean, yes, there were plenty of times
when I personally felt fear,
but I think we had nothing to fear
compared to what people living and coming up
in the black South had.
And they're the ones that really understood,
well, I mean, I talk about it today
when people talk about how hard it is to change,
you know, and I always say,
well, can you imagine what it was like in the 1940s and 50s
in the black South, you know,
that we think it was hard then, you know,
and yet people organized.
And yeah, so I don't know.
I mean, I think I almost have more fear thinking of it now,
the fact that we had a child in 1962
and pretty much brought him up in the room
between his birth in 1962 and 1965
when Highlanders shifted and started working more
in Appalachia and why I think, you know,
about some of the situations where we had a baby,
was it excuse me more now?
I mean, I think when you're in a movement
and you're with colleagues who are in it so totally
and you're seeing the courage of other people,
you can overcome your fear or you can,
I don't know, it just takes a little bit different place
in life, but, you know, as an adult now looking back
and knowing what I know about this country
and knowing how much life there is,
I think I'm more part of it.
I carry the fear more now than I had with the time.
Really good, really good.
Here's a tree of light.
There's a little tree.
We've got it all.
Here's a tree of light.
We've all got it right.
Hate you got it right.
Here's a tree of light.
All of my children,
we all got it right.
Hate we got it right.
Here's a tree of light.
Minch by each and roll by roll.
Sample plus these seeds are gross.
All of my children,
each and roll by roll.
Sample plus these seeds are gross.
Sample more than from below
till the rain comes on and down.
Hate you got it right.
We've all got it right.
Good tree of light.
Yes, there can be.
Ties it by.
Friends you are.
Lashed in kind.
Don't you travel under and wide.
You're not alone.
When you've got to tie that mind.
Sample plus these seeds are gross.
You can't remember.
The struggles lost in us.
Just the one we think of.
No, it's just in the light.
Sample plus these seeds are gross.
Friends you are.
Lashed in kind.
Don't you travel under and wide.
You're not alone.
When you've got to tie that mind.
I know your voice is from the stake of that.
Your voice is from the stake of all.
I recognize you in a crowded room.
Thank you.
This is a funny story, but I love this.
We have a great friend.
His name is Ed Cabel.
He's a West Virginia African American.
He's very strong on how long African American people have been.
West Virginia and the strong history that they have.
He talks about coming to a workshop at Highlander.
He had a met guy yet.
It was a mixed group of people.
The music started up.
He's looking around.
He's looking at the street.
The music started up.
We have a great friend.
He's very strong on how to sing.
He is a nice person.
He is a beautiful singer.
and also by people in general, in Epinophobia.
Or in the now.
Now he's in a realm Georgia.
A realm Georgia, I guess.
Mr. Kuhl, I want to ask you.
You mentioned that question of the hopefulness
that once there was something that boy
that everybody up back then, and maybe in that way
of contrast to maybe how we feel about some of these things
in the present day.
I wonder kind of how you both watch the movement of all
the through the mid 60s.
And I think in 67 you would go out to California
and teach for some of you.
I just wonder about how you were,
especially when you call yourself watched the movement.
Well, I think, again, we were very lucky to be
based at Highlander or to have the connection with Highlander
through the 1960s.
Because I know you've heard from other people in 1965.
It's really when white people were challenged.
I mean, the white people were voted out of SNCC.
And there was a growing cynicism about how racism was really
going to be dealt with or overcoming.
But I think Highlander, and again, I give miles a lot of credit
for this, took that just very seriously,
and said, that's right.
Miles was very clear that black people
are leading the civil rights movement.
And we can play an educational and supportive role.
When white people got challenged to go work
where racism lived and white communities
and also just build allies for the black movement,
Miles thought that was a great idea.
So there was a big shift at Highlander
set them I had already gone to work with Martin Luther King's
organization, the Cary and the Citizenship School Program,
Bernie Robinson, who stayed with Highlander longer,
went on to work with Septimide, and at that point.
And new people, one thing about Highlander
is the staff changes through time.
And it reflects the constituency that you're planning
to work with.
So in the mid 1960s, some Apple Action people came on the staff.
And there was a whole period where the Highlander staff members
would get back up into the Apple Action communities
and learn what were issues in the map.
And what did these basically white communities want
to work on?
And just on the hope question, I learned from Miles
that for a place like Highlander, where
you're hoping to get people in motion,
you look for places where people have anger and hope.
They're really mad about something,
but they're hopeful that something can change.
So the shift at the Apple Action was kind of looking at that.
Who's angry about what?
And who's hopeful enough that something might be done about it?
So we had already made a shift.
We've been living on Johns Island in 1963 and 1965.
Nobody on Johns Island told us it was time to get out of there.
You all have already interviewed Bill Saunders.
He was one of the key people we were working with,
but also his side-jankers and some of the older musicians,
people who carried the traditions here.
We didn't get a direct message from anybody
that we should leave Johns Island, but we were just beginning
to feel like we were listening to what was going on in South.
And we wondered how appropriate it is, as is it for us
to just be so immersed in a black community
and having all our contacts in the black community
and trying to do these, we were putting on festivals,
but really showcased the traditional music here.
We began to question ourselves whether that was appropriate.
So we had moved up to New York for two years.
We lived in Picsfield, New York.
And the idea was to get out some of the materials
we've been collecting and we were still basically
earning our living through guys' music.
So guy thought, well, I'll work again on my singing career.
So while we're living in Picsfield,
we get to call from Highlander
that they're starting to do, work up an Appalachian,
would be interested in spending a period of time
being part of the Highlander team,
listening to what's going on in the mountains.
So we went up to Pike County, Kentucky.
To say it was a big contrast from living either in Picsfield
or in the black town.
We were at big learning experience there.
And even before we went up there,
we went up to Pike County for about six months.
But even before we went,
Guy had had a call from Pitsa College in California.
It has a lot to do with best haws, actually.
There was a guy teaching political science
at Pitsa in Inlusion, like he,
and he was a really good fan of best and which haws.
And I don't know.
I don't actually remember exactly if best talk to him
or how he knew what guy was doing in Kentucky,
but anyway, Lucian called and said,
you know, there's this new college.
It's a very experimental college,
emphasizing the social sciences.
And we just wondered if you might be interested
in coming and teaching, of course there.
And our son was ready to start kindergarten.
And we were, you know, not sure what our next move
was gonna be.
So, Guy said, yeah, he thought he,
that would be interesting to go back to Claremont,
to community to put somebody in school.
I always laugh about this though.
We made the move.
We got out there, guy started teaching
and Evan started kindergarten.
And after he'd been in kindergarten
for about three weeks, he came home and he said,
isn't it about time to be moving on?
He was used to moving from community to community.
He thought it was a little dull.
And Guy must have thought so too,
because after one semester, he developed
an Appalachian Field Study Program
where he would actually take students from Pitzer
and also from Pomona down into the mountains
for a semester or so.
Because you have a, the Appalachian song.
So I remember you did one high home, the Apple Tree.
Yeah, Apple'm pictures you sucker feel!
Years ago?
Hey, I'll make you feel something.
Right.
Coach come home.
How's the words go?
Guys, it's my friends you are
The last in class
Brody trap, a wonder and wonder
You're not alone when you've got the time that I'm in
I was written by a wonderful apple acting songwriter
Joan Boyd, somebody that we worked with here at Highlander
She's a school teacher up in Big Stone, yeah
Where did she know?
Big Stone, yeah
Come play
Yeah, well, hello to the little bird
From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian
National Museum of African American History and Culture